represent peter corrosion but open the
hearing um
conference continuation of house bill
welcome everybody
good morning good morning welcome
discussions that we had before
many of the things that are back in here
are things
that the senate was not happy with in
the original version of the house bill
we did not want the data going to
the representatives for the senator
we wanted to go to the you know the
secretary of state to produce it and the
ag being the one who
reviews it because they could get data
that would not be appropriate to give to
the representatives of the senators
and that generated a
fiscal note well i guess the whole
senate amendment
generated a fiscal note from the
ag's office that said that implementing
uh what was in there was going to cost
at least a half a million dollars
um i explained to the representative the
ag that
was not our intent but speaking directly
to the amendment
uh i'm not happy about lunch
24th and 27th i want don't want the
report to go
to anyone other than secretary of state
the ag
so all of that would have to change
the number of absentee ballots
that were requested by any community
isn't as important to me
as the percentage that you know of
voters because
you know if i have
you know a request from a community you
know that's
two percent even though it may be a
large number
uh but you know in a small community
it makes a difference on the numbers and
stuff
um i think that the three could
go up to five could go up to ten on
the number of ballots sent because we
really are
looking for some kind of nefarious act
d the 20 most common addresses if you
send all the data to them
and they have the ability to sort it
they can sort it any way they want
and further information secretary of
state
working together under what they already
have
the ability to do so again
i think we're just too far apart on this
and trying to
to come up with a resolution uh in
the bills that are already passed we did
add
in the feature where people are supposed
to supply one of the three things
and that was the last four digits social
security number
the driver's license number of state or
other
information that the clerk
can verify and if you don't like my
language
i don't like your language and
i don't see that that we've got time to
get there
but i
speaking for myself personally i don't
want this the data going to
the senators or the representatives it's
the wrong place to go
limits the data that you can send it
limits the data that they
pag would have a chance to look at and
would cause the
review of that data to take a lot longer
we're not looking at ones or twos you
know we're looking at something that
would
would impact an election so
i'll let any of the other senators that
want to speak
speak but i can't do you remember
i did speak i also spoke with the ag's
office yesterday and
they have something that they have some
concerns
um on the language
actually both from the house and the
senate um and i have really concerns
about the um
the fiscal note that we
we have on it now what i would
um what i would propose
because i do think this this piece of
legislation is needed
um i think that
i would work with uh representative
griffin and representative um
hill this summer to try and put
something together that would work for
both
um and and with the ag's office because
i want to get that one of them in the
secretary of state
so that's something that both sides can
look at and
um not have to worry about the community
of conferences i think both
both have some issues but i'd rather
work on work on it over the summer with
the representatives and get something
through
this fall okay
i would just echo many of the same uh
comments of my colleagues
what we got for us is workable they
certainly don't think there's time here
to
resolve these issues
great
again in my opinion if we go back to the
sentence version
i can support that we may want to add a
word or two in there for the
attorney general to say that you know
the scope is limited you know uh that
you know this is a review of a report
it's not the investigation
because if something in that report
leads them to believe
that there is some nefarious act that's
going on
they've already got under rsa
7c6 i believe it is all the authority
that they need to go investigate that
um so you know that's
that's as far as i'm willing to go i
don't know that senator burksell is
willing to go there
and i don't know whether senator
christie didn't want to get there
either i think that worksmithingnet at
this point i
again i think we need we need a lot more
time and
we have by three o'clock this afternoon
that's why you know i'm more than
willing to work with
the representatives to get something
through that we can
work on i agree with senator hertzell
that we
it if you don't look you're never gonna
find
okay and so we have taken some action
this
this year uh in putting in
some form of identification that doesn't
uh mean that somebody has to have a
camera have a phone
have a whatever uh to be able to prove
something i mean how many people know
who the efficient
the person who actually married you is
if you were married to the state of new
hampshire
i mean you put that on the forum i was
married by
they can go look up your marriage
certificate in the clerk's office
that's pretty good you know information
to me okay
it's not going to be that person that's
out stealing things off of the list or
whatever
and there's a myriad of things that they
can do so we have taken action
but not this action and if we're going
to do this action
i want to keep it small i want to keep
looking at the high points
and i want to make it so that
we're not limiting the information that
we can give to the ag
because we're also giving it to the
general court
person
representatives
outside
thank you um i'm happy to work on the
bill over the summer i have to tell i'm
surprised about the fiscal note
so first i've heard about a fiscal note
and as when it came over to
us we didn't get that exactly and that's
um
nick had contacted me yesterday
i saw the um apparently he had
sent it no we didn't get it i don't know
where it went
um and he kind of triggered
me to call him and that's when i looked
at
it and i didn't i'm sorry i didn't make
a copy of it but it's close to
half a million dollars well i think but
i think the original scope of what was
sent over right
right i think um that's that's what
generated me thinking that
what he was thinking the bill was doing
is not what we had
what we had um
intended so i realized there's
a really a lack of communication between
the ag's office
and and us that we need to get them
involved
to realize what actually we're asking
them to do
i i don't think there's much
communication that's
what triggered me thinking
if information
i guess i don't understand how that
compromises
the information you've got the address
that it's sent to in here
i think that's an open question is
whether that is releasable under rsa91a
i think that age especially in these
where we're going to have multiple
valves into a single address
i think that that is a very important
piece of information
and could very much limit the number of
investigations
that you could do you know if it's all
19 20 year old
it's in the community that is known for
colleges like boston
or whatever you know that that would
be things that we we wouldn't want them
to spend any more time on
uh and there's other things in there
that that could be useful to that
investigator
that could be put into those reports and
again
it is not the legislator's job to go
do all of that and
i can't i can't get there i guess i what
i'm seeing here is more that we're
saying that's the secretary of state's
job
and i think some of this comes back to
your comment about
wordsmithing on this and making it clear
i think in all of this we have
some goals but we don't have the right
words to get to those goals
but the goal is one of the goals as i
would see it is that the secretary of
state
secretary of state is routinely
evaluating these things
and if everything is clean yet he's
never involved
it's just the secretary of state if he's
in charge of election
law the ag will never be involved if
there are issues that
raise a red
it's clear that i do agree that
far apart
agreement that the premise of the bill
was a good idea or something that we
should go forward
i absolutely think so um based on the
information that representative
brought in the last session um
and i mean i can expound on that
you know privately but i i think
there are some concerns on um if there
are
absentee ballots going to address
more absolute balance that go into
addresses i think you really need to
find out
i agree i don't care if they're college
age or otherwise
that's not the issue of the issues
the only reason i brought up the college
age
is that when representative hill
presented
from the committee last year as you know
senator suspect on the committee at that
time
that that was one of the explanations
that was used that some of these
are not problems because they are and
speaking personally my granddaughter who
just
graduated from quinnipiac you know they
rented an apartment building okay
uh you know probably 50 or 60 apartments
in there
and the kids instead of sending the
mail to the campus address because they
had to walk an extra half a mile
had their emails sent to the actual post
office address
and so you know you know out of that
there could have been
five or ten you know students from
somewhere in new hampshire but you know
that were there
and so again yeah but it's good to
clarify
further comments
[Music]
uh
is this it for all of you or not